>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HERE IN SPITE OF IT ALL.
WE HAVE SPENT AN AWFUL LOT OF
TIME TELLING YOU WHAT WE THINK
ABOUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WE DO IT ALMOST EVERY NIGHT.
A LITTLE REPUGNANT.
FOR TONIGHT, FOR ONCE, WE ARE GG
TO LET THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SPEAK FOR ITSELF.
THIS SHOW HAS OBTAINED SOME
RECENTLY SHOT FOOTAGE OF
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS, THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, OR VICE VERSA
DEPENDING ON YOUR VIEW.
FOOTAGE THAT SHOWS THEM IN THEIR
PRIVATE MOMENTS, DEEP WITHIN THE
FEDERAL COMPOUND IN WASHINGTON.
IT IS A REMARKABLE WINDOW INTO
WHO THESE PEOPLE REALLY ARE, AND
MAY BE THE MOST REMARKABLE THING
ABOUT IT IS THAT THIS VIDEO
COMES FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ITSELF.
THEY RELEASED IT, APPARENTLY ON
PURPOSE.
THEY WANTED YOU TO SEE IT.
THEY THOUGHT YOU WOULD BE
IMPRESSED.
THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD MAKE THEM
LOOK GOOD.
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS YOU WATCH
THIS FIRST CLIP.
THIS FOOTAGE IS FROM
KAMALA HARRIS' "SURPRISE"
BIRTHDAY PARTY THE OTHER DAY.
HERE IT IS.
>> SURPRISE!
♪♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU ♪♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
♪♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU ♪
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU ♪
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY ♪
♪ HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU ♪♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: IN THE ENTIRE
HISTORY OF SAD PARTIES, THAT HAS
GOT TO TAKE FIRST PLACE.
IT IS LIKE A ROOMFUL OF ALIENS
HAVE GATHERED TO ACT OUT THIS
CONCEPT THEY JUST HEARD ABOUT
CALLED HAPPINESS.
THE HEAD ALIEN IS A
SUPERNATURALLY STRANGE BEING
CALLED KAMALA HARRIS, WHO FOR
REASONS NO ONE EVER EXPLAINS,
WALKS INTO A ROOM IN THE MOST
SECURE BUILDING IN THE WORLD
WITH A PIECE OF ELASTICIZED
FABRIC OVER HER FACE, BUT THAT
IS TOTALLY NORMAL, JUST AS THE
MASKED BIRTHDAY CELEBRATION,
THIS KAMALA HARRIS JUST THEN WAS
OVER TO A MAN THEY CLAIM IS HER
HUSBAND, WHO LIKE HER IS FOR
LEASE B23ED, AND HE FOR SOME
REASON AS A MASK ON HIS FACE TOO
WHICH SUGGEST THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY LIVE TOGETHER OR
INDEED HAVE EVER MET.
WE DON'T KNOW THE TRUTH BUT
WHATEVER IT IS, THE TWO OF THEM
PROCEED TO PANTOMIME THE MOST
SEXLESS IMITATION OF A KISS
IMAGINABLE, AWKWARDLY RUBBING
FACES THROUGH THE GAUZE.
AND THEN COME AS IF IT COULD GET
WEIRDER, HARRIS SUDDENLY YELLS
"SURPRISE" AT HER OWN SURPRISE
BIRTHDAY PARTY, LIKE SHE IS
HOSTING THE EVENT FOR ONE OF HER
MULTIPLE PERSONALITIES.
WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON HERE?
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?
OH, JUST OUR LEADERS, THE PEOPLE
WHO RUN THE COUNTRY.
THEN IT GETS TRULY BIZARRE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO, AGAIN
INTENTIONALLY RELEASED BY THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS OFFICE, OF
JOE BIDEN IN A HALLWAY.
HE TOTTERS ALONG LIKE A NURSING
HOME PATIENT IN THE FINAL
STRETCH, CLEARLY UNAWARE OF HIS
SURROUNDINGS OR WHAT HE IS
CARING IN HIS OWN HANDS.
SPOILER ALERT, THEY ARE FLOWERS.
WATCH.
[LAUGHTER]
>> REALLY?
OH, JOE!
AWW, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OH, LOOK AT HOW GORGEOUS.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE.
OH, I'M GOING TO HANG THIS UP.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT!
>> YOU ARE WELCOME.
>> Tucker: THE CAMERA CATCHES
HER MASKED ALONE IN HER OWN
OFFICE.
AND THEN SHE TALKS "OH, JOE, I
AM VERY TOUCHED," SAYS THIS
ALIEN POSING AS VICE PRESIDENT.
SHE USED THE WORD GORGEOUS, THEY
WERE NO ACTUAL HUMAN BEING HAS
USED SINCE 1977.
THERE IS EVEN, IF YOU LISTEN FOR
IT, A FAKE KISS SOUND IN THERE.
WE ARE ASSUMING HARRIS MADE THAT
SOUND, ALTHOUGH IT IS POSSIBLE
THERE AND PLAYING A SOUNDTRACK
IN THE BACKGROUND.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THEY WANT YOU TO
SEE THIS, WHICH IS INTERESTING.
YOU CAN TELL A LOT ABOUT THE
REGIME BY THE PROPAGANDA IT
PRODUCES, NORTH KOREA PUTS ON A
LOT OF
PROPAGANDA.
JUST THE OTHER DAY, THEY
RELEASED VIDEO OF SOLDIERS
BREAKING CONCRETE SLABS WITH
THEIR BARE HANDS, LYING DOWN
THROUGH SHIRTLESS ON BROKEN
GLASS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE DEFENDING
NORTH KOREA, BACK OFF OR WE WILL
EAT YOU.
OKAY, GOT IT.
BUT WHAT IS THE MESSAGE OF THE
JOE AND KAMALA VIDEOS?
ALL YOUR NIGHTMARES ARE REAL?
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OR EVEN
WORSE THAN YOU THOUGHT THEY
WERE?
KAMALA MAY HAVE SEEMED KIND OF
FAKE TO YOU OR JOE MAY HAVE
LOOKED A LITTLE OUT OF IT, BUT
ACTUALLY THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT
TELLING US YOU DON'T KNOW THE
HALF OF IT.
IT IS POSSIBLE, HARRIS IS AN
ACTUAL ROBOT WITH BATTERIES, THE
NEW FRONTIER OF AI.
JOE BIDEN ISN'T JUST PUNCHY, HE
IS BARELY CONSCIOUS.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE THEY ARE
SENDING.
IT IS REALLY STRANGE.
AND IT HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
WHILE.
REMEMBER LAST YEAR WHEN
JOE BIDEN READ FROM A NOTE CARD
THAT KAMALA HARRIS WOULD BE HIS
VICE PRESIDENT?
THIS WAS THE ANNOUNCEMENT VIDEO
THEY RELEASED.
>> HI, HI, SORRY TO KEEP YOU.
>> THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
ARE YOU READY TO GO TO WORK?
>> OH, MY GOD, I AM SO READY TO
GO TO WORK.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IS THE ANSWER
YES?
>> THE ANSWER IS ABSOLUTELY YES,
AND I'M READY TO DO THIS WITH
YOU, FOR YOU, I AM JUST, I AM
DEEPLY HONORED, AND I AM VERY
EXCITED.
>> Tucker: WALL.
THAT IS JUST BEYOND BELIEF.
SO WHY WOULD THE PEOPLE AROUND
JOE BIDEN WANT THE PUBLIC TO SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
MAYBE THEY DON'T CARE.
MAYBE THEY ARE NOT EMBARRASSED
OF JOE BIDEN'S CONDITION.
MAYBE IN FACT HIS CONDITION WAS
THE WHOLE POINT OF MAKING AND
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT IS UNIMAGINABLE.
A GROUP OF POLITICAL OPERATIVES
IN ISTANBUL INSTALLED A SULTAN
OF THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE.
HE SPENT HIS DAYS BABBLING LIKE
AN INFANT AND THROWING COINS TO
BIRDS.
OCCASIONALLY IF HE WAS FEELING
SPORTY, HE WOULD KNOCK THE
TURBINE OFF SOMEBODY ELSE'S
HEAD, HE WAS COMPLETELY
DEMENTED.
HE RARELY LEFT THE PALACE AND
WHEN HE DID HE SPOKE FROM A
SCRIPT BUT THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM
CERTAINLY KNEW.
THEY PREFERRED HIM THAT WAY.
HE WAS EASIER TO CONTROL.
WHATEVER YOU THINK OF HIM,
JOE BIDEN IS DEFINITELY EASY TO
CONTROL.
YOU RECALL THIS CLIP IN WHICH
BIDEN KEPT REFERRING TO
SOMETHING AS THE HARRIS-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THE HARRIS-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
RELAUNCH THAT EFFORT AND MAKE IT
EASIER FOR MILITARY SPOUSES AND
VETERANS TO FIND MEANINGFUL
CAREERS.
>> Tucker: AGAIN, THESE ARE
PREPARED REMARKS, WE CAN'T SAY
THAT ENOUGH.
THESE ARE STATEMENTS THAT THE
BIDEN PEOPLE ARE MAKING
VOLUNTARILY.
SO MANY OF THEM ARE LIKE THAT.
THEY ARE NOT GAFFES.
THEY ARE WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO
SEE.
IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR,
KAMALA HARRIS, WHO GREW UP IN
CANADA, A FOREIGN COUNTRY, SWORE
THAT SHE WITNESSED "MULTIPLE
GENERATIONS OF HER FAMILY
CELEBRATING KWANZAA," AN
AMERICAN HOLIDAY INVENTED IN
LONG BEACH, CALIFORNIA, AFTER
KAMALA HARRIS WAS BORN.
>> MY SISTER AND I, WE GREW UP
CELEBRATING KWANZAA.
EVERY YEAR, OUR FAMILY AND OUR
EXTENDED FAMILY, WE WOULD GATHER
AROUND ACROSS MULTIPLE
GENERATIONS AND WE WOULD TELL
STORIES, THE KIDS WOULD SIT ON
THE CARPET AND THE ELDERS WOULD
SIT IN CHAIRS, SO TO EVERYONE
WHO IS CELEBRATING, HAPPY
KWANZAA FROM OUR FAMILY TO
YOURS.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
OUR FAMILY.
THAT IS JUST CRAZY!
THAT THEY WOULD PUT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT I WOULD.
NOT ONE WORD IS TRUE, BUT NOT
ONE WORD IS BELIEVABLE.
AGAIN, IT WAS A PREPARED
STATEMENT, IT WAS CAREFULLY
CONSIDERED.
BUT THEY DID NOT EVEN BOTHER TO
LOOK AT A CALENDAR.
IT WAS LIKE WHEN KAMALA HARRIS
SAID THAT TUPAC WAS THE BEST
RAPPER ALIVE YEARS AFTER HE
DIED.
WHEN YOU'RE MAKING HISTORY YOU
DO NOT CARE ABOUT CHRONOLOGY OR
FACTS, WE HAVE NEVER HAD A
VICE PRESIDENT WHO LOOKS LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS THE WORDS DO NOT
LONGER MATTER.
THAT IS THE REAL MESSAGE.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS WHAT
KAMALA HARRIS LOOKS LIKE, SHE ON
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
IN 19625, THE ACTUAL
MARTIN LUTHER KING TOLD A STORY
ABOUT THE CIVIL RIGHTS MARCH IN
BIRMINGHAM, ALABAMA, AND AT THAT
MARCH A POLICE OFFICER ASKED A
YOUNG GIRL, MR. PRESIDENT, WHAT
DO YOU WANT?
IN KINGS TELLING COMEAU "THE
LITTLE GIRL LOOKED HIM STRAIGHT
IN THE EYE AND ANSWERED "FREEDO.
HERE IS KAMALA HARRIS' VERSION
OF THE SAME STORY, THIS TIME
STARTING MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
MODERN REINCARNATION,
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> SHE WOULD TELL THE STORY
ABOUT HOW THEY WERE MARCHING,
AND THIS WAS BACK WHEN THEY
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE ARMRESTS AND
SEAT BELTS.
[LAUGHTER]
SO THEY ARE MARCHING AWAY, YOU
KNOW, SHOUTING AND ALL OF THAT,
AND I THINK IT WAS MY UNCLE
FREDDIE, YOU KNOW, LOOKED DOWN,
LOOKED IN THE STROLLER, WHICH
WAS EMPTY --
[LAUGHTER]
AND SAID "WHERE IS KAMALA?"
AND APPARENTLY THEY LEFT ME A
BLOCK BY, I HAD FALLEN OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE YOU GO.
AND THEN MY MOTHER TELLS A FUNNY
STORY ABOUT HOW ONE DAY -- I WAS
FUSSING, YOU KNOW, I WAS CUSSING
AND FUSSING, IT IS MUCH CUTER
WHEN SHE WOULD TELL THE STORY,
BUT SHE WOULD LOOK DOWN, WHAT
DO YOU WANT, WHAT DO YOU WANT?
AND I LOOKED BACK UP AND I SAID
"FREEDOM!"
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: WOW.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THAT IS ON
MARTIN LUTHER KING, THE CANADIAN
VERSION, EXCEPT WITHOUT THE
WISDOM, THE INSIDE, THE
RESTRAINT, OR THE ELOQUENCE,
BUT WITH A BRAND-NEW, HIGHLY
CREEPY, ENGINEERED LAUGH, A
NOISE THAT ACCORDING TO
ZOOLOGIST SCARES THE HELL OUT OF
SQUIRRELS AND OTHER SMALL
WOODLAND CREATURES.
BUT MAY BE LIKE IT.
MAYBE YOU WANT TO HEAR A WHOLE
LOT MORE TERRIFYINGLY CRAZY FAKE
LAUGHTER FROM A HIGHLY AMBITIOUS
LADY WITH DEAD EYES.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS BETTING THAT
YOU DO.
SO TO ACCOMMODATE YOUR
BOTTOMLESS APPETITE FOR BEING
PATRONIZED BY KAMALA HARRIS,
THEY RELEASED THIS VIDEO IN
WHICH SHE TALKS ABOUT SPACE.
>> I JUST LOVE THE IDEA OF
FLYING IN THE UNKNOWN.
THINGS THAT WE JUST HAVEN'T
FIGURED OUT OR DISCOVERED YET.
JUST THINK ABOUT SO MUCH THAT IS
OUT THERE THAT WE STILL HAVE TO
LEARN.
LIKE, I LOVE THAT.
I LOVE THAT.
SO I AM VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
SPACE COUNSEL.
YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO LITERALLY
SEE THE CRATERS ON THE MOON WITH
YOUR OWN EYES.
WITH YOUR OWN EYES, I'M TELLING
YOU, IT IS GOING TO BE
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
I'M TELLING YOU.
IT IS FUNNY, YOU IMAGINE OFTEN
THAT THE TRUTH IS HIDDEN AWAY.
WE WILL NEVER REALLY GET TO WHAT
THE TRUTH IS.
BUT IT'S NOT VERY OFTEN THE
TRUTH IS RIGHT THERE, IT IS
RIGHT IN THE VIDEO, JUST LOOK AT
THE VIDEO.
THAT IS THE TRUTH, IT IS THE
TRUTH THEY WANT YOU TO SEE, AND
FOR THAT REASON, IT IS DEEPLY
REVEALING.
THAT VIDEO TELLS YOU EVERYTHING.
ONE OF THOSE KIDS LISTENING TO
KAMALA HARRIS TALKING ABOUT
SPACE, WE LATER LEARNED, WAS A
CHILD ACTOR, YET HE WAS STILL
THE MOST GENUINE PERSON IN THAT
VIDEO.
IT'S KIND OF NUTS WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
THESE PEOPLE LITERALLY HAVE NO
IDEA HOW ABSURD THEY LOOK, AND
HOW COULD THEY, THEY LIVE IN A
TINY AIRLESS CULT WHERE EVERYONE
PRETENDS THAT JOE BIDEN IS FULLY
COMPETENT AND KAMALA HARRIS IS A
CIVIL RIGHTS HERO.
IT IS JONESTOWN.
THE CLIPS WE JUST PLAYED ARE THE
DOCUMENT TERRY EVIDENCE THAT
HISTORIANS OF THE FUTURE WILL
STUDY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO AMERICA.
BEHIND THE HEAVILY GUARDED WALLS
OF THE WHITE HOUSE, EVERYONE HAS
GONE CRAZY.
JUST THIS WEEK, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DECLARED THAT A
BIOLOGICAL MAN WHO WEARS A DRESS
IS NOW A FEMALE, AND THEN THEY
SAID THAT BRAVE OR COSTAR
FEMALE ADMIRAL OUT TO DELIVER
A SPEECH THAT READ LIKE
SOMETHING OUT OF A TV
DOCUMENTARY.
WATCH.
>> I AM TRULY HONORED TO JOIN
THE RANKS OF MEN AND WOMEN
ACROSS THIS GREAT NATION WHO
HAVE COMMITTED TO DEFEND THE
UNITED STATES AGAINST SMALL AND
LARGE THREATS, KNOWN AND
UNKNOWN.
I AM HONORED TO SERVE AS THE
FIRST FEMALE FOUR STAR OFFICER
OF THE U.S. PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE COMMISSIONED CORPS.
>> Tucker: COME ON.
THEY ARE DARING YOU TO SIT THERE
AND NOT SAY THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
SORRY, IT IS RIDICULOUS.
SORRY, NOT PLAYING ALONG!
BUT THEY DON'T THINK IT IS.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF,
HOW LONG WILL IT BE BEFORE
JOE BIDEN APPOINTS TO THE
SUPREME COURT?
AND WHEN HE INEVITABLY DOES
THAT, HOW LONG WILL IT BE UNTIL
CNN INFORMS US THIS I